[Música]
americanos que son injustos americanos
que son mentirosos americanos que son
matones estadounidenses cuyas palabras
no significan nada
están tratando de decir que solo hay
manera un terrorista irán les golpeó en
la cara
y hasta donde yo sé en la noche del 22
de enero hora de beijing china por
invitación de la ms se unirá a otros
países afectados por la epidemia y
participará en la reunión del comité de
emergencia del reglamento sanitario
internacional
[Música]
we all of living no participaremos en
una carrera feroz hasta el final no
saldremos de la unión europea para
socavar las normas comunitarias no
participaremos en ningún tipo de presión
ya sea comercial social o medioambiental
y no sólo escuchen lo que decimos miren
lo que hacemos
we say
we
trump ha sido acusado para siempre no
importa lo que diga a los titulares que
quiera sacar está acusado para siempre
nunca liberará esta cicatriz
tepper puesto que shopper firmar un
procedimiento estoy a punto de firmar un
decreto que se puede resumir en me quedo
en casa ya no habrá zona roja
no habrá zona 1 ni zona 2 en la
península no existe la pgje la zona 1 en
la zona de la península si sabrá italia
italia como zona protegida
[Música]
round the clock lado ms ha evaluado esta
epidemia durante todo el día y estamos
profundamente preocupados tanto por los
alarmantes niveles de propagación y
gravedad por los alarmantes niveles de
contagio hemos estimado que el kobe 19
posiblemente podría estar caracterizado
como una pandemia
me quedé donde ese hombre tomó su último
aliento
me paré donde este hombre respiro por
última vez no saben cómo se siente eso
la explosión no quedará sin rendición de
cuentas los responsables de esta
catástrofe pagarán el precio
esta es una promesa para los mártires y
los heridos es un compromiso nacional lo
que pasó anoche en bogotá no solamente
lamentable
es posiblemente lo más grave que haya
pasado en nuestra ciudad
[Música]
tenemos que ir de nuevo al campo porque
si no vamos al nuevo campo nuestro asilo
será rechazado
las condiciones de la ley marcial en
unos minutos firmaré un decreto sobre la
movilización general y pediré a toda la
población que se una en torno al
gobierno de la sac y armenia estar atrás
[Música]